il ya greg guillotin qui nous a préparés
annabelle annabelle alors ça je vous dis
ne manquaient pas et ne manquez pas la
fin qu'ordinaire fut sketch il est où il
fait très peur mais vous inquiétez pas
il est gentil rester avec nous et rester
surtout pour la dernière séquence et
vous allez voir regardez bien le mec sur
la dernière séquence le téléphone
dix neuf huit sept six cinq quatre trois
deux fois cause
je dérange
[Musique]
après vaud
quel étage sera la tâche de me rendre au
annabelle tu aimes les endroits
annabelle n'aime pas le chiffre 3 après
faire le 0 3 2 1
c'est mon âme est belle même ramené
hongrois
elle a même pas ce qu'est fraude
annabelle n'aime pas ceux qui fraudent
cinq quatre trois piquets wafa saison
[Musique]
anna belknap à la cigarette
éteignez votre cigarette à dire la belle
jeu que je les tue 5 4 3
c'était une blague c'est pas énorme
ces normes farouchement mali là nous
sommes pas franchement la main le mec se
bat mais le mec se bat et se retrouve
totalement est l'hôte avec le sac elle
le fera casque